What's that you're reading, Kathy?
This? Oh, it's a new novel I just bought.
I'm just starting it, but so far it seems pretty good.
Do you like reading books?
Yes, it's one of my hobbies.
Can I have a look at it?
Sure. It's the latest book by Stephen King. Do you like him?
Have you ever read any of his books?
No, but I've definitely heard of him. He's really famous, isn't he?
Yes, he is. In fact, he's one of the most famous authors in America.
His books are always so scary; I love scary novels.
I think they're OK, but I prefer spy thrillers.
Ah, you mean books with a lot of action and adventure?
Yes, they're real page-turners. My favorite novel is "Harry Potter."
Harry Potter? I hate it.